there's a reason Formula One Champions
and Russian billionaires live in Geneva
money wealthy foreigners can take
advantage of a forfeit a flat tax that
helps them duck major costs introduced
in 1862 to get wealthy Brits to pay for
local Services before Faye and Geneva
generated around 750 million dollars in
the six years to 2012. but some
politicians say it can mean tax rates of
less than one percent and now they want
it to stop and if the city's people vote
through the referendum could the wealthy
flee
in 2009 Zurich was the first Swiss City
to abolish the forfeit nearly half the
wealthy foreigners who benefited soon
left although most to other parts of
Switzerland Swiss bank sent Exodus of
their clients could damage to the local
economy as a result while Geneva's
Chamber of Commerce says thousands of
jobs could go but don't worry there's
still plenty of options the UK Belgium
and Portugal are just some of the
countries still offering tax breaks to
foreign millionaires